so welcome everyone to the Civic punch
if we're going to get started those of
you who are sitting way in the back
there you know move up a little bit
there's our closer chairs you want to be
able to see better pretty excited to
introduce Evan Henshaw clap also known
as rabble also known as an article geek
so Evan let's see was created protests
met back in the 90s mid to late 19th was
instrumental in the development of the
India networking and media centers went
on to work at oh do a podcasting company
that was reported as Klan and was then
involved in the genesis of Twitter and
we're gonna hear about that today
Evan later went on to do a number of
things including starting cooperative
development shops included why working
as CTO for neo what of Jody who enjoys
companies a number of a number of other
things but when I first met Evan was in
Cancun in 2003 and unfortunately we
weren't relaxing on the beach in Cancun
now
nice we were there as part of a protest
against the World Trade Organization
meeting which was in a sort of Waldo
hotel zone it's not accessible to people
who live in Cancun and we were setting
up an in the media center to produce
people's coverage of the trade talks and
the mobilization I remember sort of
being in the media centre where we were
setting up computers and networking and
organizing things for for the action and
I was having trouble getting what a
computer network can set up I said does
anyone know you know if anyone helped me
with this and this guy was sort of under
another computer working on something
and kind of looked up and he said well
is it what's it running and I said oh I
don't know it looks like it's running
Windows and he said well there's your
problem
and he came up to install this machine
for the new media reporters for the
action so I'm really excited to hear
evan stock today and yeah this is the
funny thing is the total angle the thing
I had been doing right before that was
attempting to smuggle car loads of
computers to the Zapatistas and failing
to sneak them across the border into
Mexico because because you were too
honest to Brian who was trying to say to
you yeah I've got better driving
[Laughter]
turns out if you want a slower a do
transmitters to Indian you put them
inside desktop computers and then they
because there's no remote computer so
this talk is about Twitter one of the
things I find fascinating is that the
origin story of how something comes
about and how it gets created isn't
isn't the story that's useful for
companies when they create their own
narratives particularly for me it's
fascinating to be here at the Media Lab
because Twitter's origins really come in
large part from the Media Lab but most
people to mean I don't even know it
because I'm not sure that it was a
project of people like it wasn't the
normal commercialization route and it
wasn't entirely like the project tab was
supposed to be working on and so that
history got lost but hopefully in
telling some of the history about
Twitter got created and where it came
from I can provide some of the history
so Sasha said from 2000 to 2004 I was
traveling around the world setting up
activist media centers and trying to
build ways in which we could build
technology growth intermediate self and
by 2004 I had run out of money selling
my first company and got a job is are
doing contracting in San Francisco and
there were some folks in Cisco the time
there was no big boom there was no jobs
everything else it was easy to find
interesting people and I ran into a guy
who said I want to reinvent radio guy
name knowing much we're gonna
democratize radio and I'm like wow I've
been doing media activism
sounds really fun so we started working
cafes we started hacking on stuff and we
created this thing called audio was sort
of a standard startup we got a little
bit of angel funding and we worked
really really hard and we just kept
working and working you know this sort
of like moment which you never do and
then we launched it and we launched it
in a really traditional startup way
which is at Ted before there were any
TEDx is and in the New York Times at the
same day we showed it to no one before
this we've been still we got no feedback
no so it looked really pretty and
everyone said whoo this is great and
cool and the interface was really nice
but it lacked some serious user
experience stuff beyond the visual
interface and so not realizing that our
problem was user experience we just kept
adding features we built a tool for
recording and editing podcasts and in
the browser using flash and we just kept
working and then we kind of got hit with
Apple integrated podcasting in an ugly
way into iTunes but it had really good
user experiences or the best example of
oddly good us which is they set
everything up in nice lines they set
everything up so that you didn't get the
history and you deposit you've restarted
and none of it was pretty and you
couldn't find what the podcast you
wanted was to do but it really it worked
well and we had gone down to meet with
Apple and show them everything and
they're like oh great that's neat
we're not gonna work with you guys and
then they launched it really quickly and
so we had this kind of [ __ ] moment where
were like what do we do now
at this point we've taken about five
million dollars in venture funding we
had a team
dozen people we had an office when we're
working cafes anymore but the product
was never going to be like that big home
run and so we ended up in this lighted
like startup zombie purgatory space
where we had half a million dollars in
the bank and we had a great team of
interesting people stuff but no viable
path to like you know being what it's
called the unicorn now and so you know
this is one of our investors things like
everything was perfect like everything
that should have been lined up and what
we were doing was lined up and yet we
couldn't like get that hockey stick of
massive growth the site was profitable
like it deep it worked
high growing traffic but it was never
gonna be that turret thing so what we
should I'd to do is sort of go back and
say well rather than shut down the
office and lay everyone off let's start
doing hackathons I started this thing
back in 2005-2006 I was very active in
the Ruby on Rails community and I said
with some friends let's do a 24-hour
hackathon to show that you can build
applications at 24 hours it ended up
converting into something called rails
Rumble which is two days now
and people consistently build
applications in two days but you know 10
years ago the idea of building an
application in a day or two that was a
viable web application was a crazy idea
so we turned we organized this 50 person
hackathon remote and we did in the
office and other people in the office
was like wow you know maybe we can build
things not six months and stealth with a
with a bigger team maybe we can build
things really small quick so what we did
is we set aside every Wednesday in the
office to not work on oh do not work on
the thing we were supposed to work on
and we did a brainstorm in the morning
from like 8:00 to 9:00 a.m. and we said
all the teams have to be
cross-functional so you can never work
with someone who does the same thing as
you you're designing you can't work
designers if you're a public person you
know we're gonna we're gonna mix up the
teens and there wasn't uh like order of
it was just like pick someone you don't
normally work with and then we just all
went to our office and we just have done
stuff and moved around and built stuff
everything was like things in the back
of our head and then at 6:00 p.m. we did
a demo and it was just like what's the
fastest way we can get to trying things
out and so we built some things we built
a little app that you can post on
MySpace the social network of the time
what are you gonna record videos of
yourself through your webcam and posted
online and get a series of them and the
idea is you post one every day we added
a social level on top of the podcasting
but the time there hadn't been a social
sort of graph level and now you can have
friends you can sort of see the teeny
icons that eventually became in Twitter
and the time there was your name under
it and things like that we one of the
things we created was a collectivized
voicemail where it would look at your
address book and when you called in you
would record a message and then you
would hear all the messages of people
who you have poem in your address book
with and so it was this sort of almost
like this it was the way the Twitter
feed works except it was recorded audio
playing with pastors and then we one of
those we built was this thing called
friend stalker and for a couple weeks
friend's daughter was the name we
actually used internally before before
Noah they got an original podcasting
idea sat in the office with the Oxford
English Dictionary looking through
trying to find a name for this service
and he got all the way to team before he
discovered that Twitter actually kind of
reflected what it did and so that's how
it whitter got created you know that was
their the process by which we insane for
this
you know we have this failing podcasting
company we're interested in media a
bunch of the people on the team had
worked on honor blogspot pyrrha at
Google and they're like oh my god Google
doesn't understand social software and
they hate us and where they are the
reason we did podcasting the first place
is because they had to commute from San
Francisco down to Palo Alto for work and
so they had all this time sitting on the
Google bus and really bored it's been de
podcasting and then once we moved the
office to San Francisco and everybody
biked and walked to work no one listen
to podcasts anymore we stopped
dogfooding our own product and then all
of a sudden we got bored and built
something else so the particular
hackathon the project that made Twitter
in this case was Jack was the one who
did the thing that became friend stalker
I went back in my emails and I think the
same day we did three products that were
indistinguishably similar like one was
called ketchup and one was called linked
messages and one was called friends are
they good
I think it's one of those things where
people start like rebuilding the same
stuff Jack need to call it friends
marques cut out of it the Ford was a
deficit to developer of a team before
that he'd been a bicycle messenger in
New York and he kind of got obsessed
with those messages that they give on
the radio of where they are and mother
doing and we'd have this idea in the
team and the project that every time
there's a media shift so every time the
medium shifts from from dumb phones to
smart problems from desktop applications
to web applications from static web
applications that are every time there's
a major media shift you know what you
can do is look at the social software
look at the social connections the way
people work with the previous generation
technology and you can try and think
about what creating those modes of
interactions would be with the new media
because almost always the old technology
can't
musician and so a lot of what we were
looking at is like what what would be
the future of smartphones if smartphones
came out remember if there was no iPhone
so we're using like you know Symbian
Nokia phones and then what in the past
and we all worked on it made sense and
so through this yeah so one is a key and
in Linux when you have a shared system
which you sometimes you can have this
dog play on file and your home directory
and there's this command called finger
and you can finger people and it can
send you back they're not playing file
which are really awesome and on some of
the systems I've used and some of the
other people used this had become a
social never people would regularly
update they're not playing file about
what they're working on and that people
would finger each other to see what was
going on and it said oh there's a way in
which you can sort of have a distributed
system we do status updates and one of
the guys on the team had gone to
Carleton in Minnesota and and in
Carleton they got so obsessed with the
finger and clan files that they had
actually built a web version in the mid
90s up so you had a web interface to and
then because bunch of people had worked
on blogging there was this idea of you
know the feed reader what if there was
this flow of information that came to
you and what if there was a symmetry
about who who you read versus who you
spoke to
and what I believe sort of was the most
important influence into it was this
project that they came out of ten Hirsch
who was here at the Media Lab called Tex
mob and it was a social network root
system only for Prentiss and he worked
on it over a while and perhaps will just
show the video of it so you sort of get
a sense of what
since 1998 the Institute for applied
autonomy has developed technologies that
enable average citizens political
protesters in the functional apparently
to defend their way of life in the
summer of 2004 I hey researchers
produced text month a cell phone text
message Broadcasting System text mom
allows activists who are distributing
throughout a city Tremayne organized
during chaotic street protests text mob
users are able to use their cell phones
to send up-to-the-minute text messages
to hundreds and thousands of other
techmount users containing vital
information that are they needed medical
assistance protest meeting points and
police blockade locations text mobs
utility was proven during the 2004
Republican National Convention in New
York State when protesters were able to
bypass pre-emptive police tactics by
sharing information on undercover
officers and police movements
demonstrators in this text messages to
converge on
starsk with little or no advance warning
get your law enforcement off guard and
temporarily cease in control of this
city picked off by text mod messages
rested and unable to disperse before
police reinforcements arrived only to
reconvene around a new target
moments later such tactics often
referred to as swarming by defense
analysts at DARPA and the RAND
Corporation are considered by security
experts to be the most effective tools
at the modern activists disposal texts
mob is also an effective tool for
safeguarding the activity of democratic
elections Textron was used in the Orange
Revolution when allegations of
widespread voter fraud during Ukraine's
presidential election mobilized hundreds
of thousands of people into the streets
of Kiev text mob was also used by
demonstrators protesting the January
2005 inauguration of George W Bush in
Washington DC text model the Institute
for applied autonomy
thank the following individuals and
organizations without whose continued
efforts this type of work would not be
possible so essentially the video was
[Music]
it's a bunch of years later so yeah so
this is heaven 2004-2005 and then so
when Apple was tad was here but he was a
really terrible yeah he's a Media Lab
student time University of Washington no
and and we Francisco had found out that
this textmode thing was happening and it
was really cool and he's like I want to
do this thing to her like dad come out
to San Francisco we'll spend a weekend
hacking on stuff and we fix your
software so people out and there he is
and we spent a weekend basically
rewriting the backend of the software
and at the time SMS delivery was really
tricky and so we're like oh [ __ ] SMS is
expensive and we don't want to spend any
money so what we did is we built a
dispatch server and we built that Java
applet we hid it in a bunch of activists
webpages at the bottom of the webpage
and the Java applet would then connect
back to the distribution server and it
would run smtp and it would send through
the public email gateways for all the
delivery for all the the SMS to you know
emailed SMS gateways and because we did
it through this sort of distributed
network and we handed up
hundred thousand web pages or something
we didn't have to pay for anything you
do about forty thousand messages in our
through this thing that didn't get
blocked because that was immediately
what happened in town is before we had
that for the DNC here in Boston a few
thousand messages went through and then
all the providers blocked in and so in
the two weeks between the two we had to
write this offer
Ted was part of this work city's project
he didn't actually talk to me of much
about what he did but it was one of like
a dozen projects that he worked on you
know in preparation for this talk and
Landon looked have my full gave keynotes
at the O'Reilly of urging telepathy
conference in January 2006 so about a
month or two before the the first
Twitter prototype got bill and I talked
about text mom and I talked about a
bunch of other activist products and Tad
didn't mention that he worked on text
mom at all he talked about a another
system he'd built here for doing
simultaneous translation for Chinese
language speakers in Boston so how do
you use text messages tree so very
similar stuff to the stuff
smashing still knows about you know
technology for community organizing
thing and then after so text mom got a
lot of attention at the moment of the
art scene and then sort of disappeared
and then awhile later like years later
like four years later eventually there's
a grand jury and they want to figure out
who sent what message is and how people
were using text mode because they they
finally sort of come to realize that
there was a lot of useful information
and network analysis and figuring out
who would got what because there were
actual text messages about the burning
of a giant paper
so Todd had to deal with a bunch of
legal no I think the data was gone by
that we had four years later the chances
of the server is still being around but
so I don't think they ever know and
people weren't using like disposable
mobile phones and things like that was
you know they they go after this data a
lot and Twitter has this all the time
and before that within the media we used
to do jurisdiction hopping so we would
never put a server in the same country
of where it was covered and we would we
moved the domain name registration from
country to country every like six months
which means they had to restart all
their legal process in another country
until eventually we put it in Brazil and
it turns out that Brazil's courts are
really really slow and there are lots of
lefty Brazilian lawyers and the
Brazilians aren't very keen to follow
the first world's demands for handing
over activist information and so domain
name registration if you want to put it
in Brazil it's a good place to do it so
this is the first version of Twitter the
version that got built in that one day
it's really simple you get the updating
status to get a list of status of
everyone I think the very first version
you had default everybody following
everybody and then eventually there was
sort of this friending mechanism that
was created but we launched it all of
our friends thought it was really stupid
and no one ever used
I remember you said here's a thing and I
was like what awesome everybody's like
why would I want to do that everybody
and the TechCrunch at the press and our
investors and everybody got exactly the
same reaction this is the stupidest move
of any startup that's happened in
Silicon Valley the investors of Charles
River ventures here in their answer to
this was fire everybody shut it down
delete the servers there's still a
couple million dollars in the bank we
can have a we can get 50% of our money
back this is worthless a couple of years
later they go back and say oh [ __ ] foot
is becoming successful and they Bank
their way back in so they can claim they
were the original investors and Twitter
and so they ended up making a lot of
money in it but at the time their answer
was kill this and kill it as fast as
possible if you can't sell it to someone
we were we were lucky one of the guys on
the team was the original angel investor
Evan Williams he was our angel investor
and we worked out of his likable
Department for a bunch of months and
then he he had worked up bloggers and
sold it to Google and last kombuchas he
decided they were antisocial and Chris
Anderson from Ted came like a phone call
said hey am what are you doing and he
didn't want to say that I've been
traveling around the world and taking
cooking classes
so he said looked at the only thing he
had done one angel investment he was
like well there's o dó thing on you know
my investor day
I'm helping make this podcasting thing
and and Chris from antennas like all
podcasting that sounds cool it sounds
him and so after so instead of saying
yes I'll give you the invite to attend
10 which is all that wanted there like
will launch it at 10 and so that's how
we ended up launching attention after
that he actually joined as a as an
active person is really good product so
at the time Charles River ventures is
like shut it all down
this is an embarrassment it he's like
well I'm gonna take almost all my money
and buying out the investors and keep
going with this thing because I think
it's interesting and there at the time
Twitter a really really few users the
original homepage would show the most
recent tweets and you could reload it
and even six months a year in you like
reload it and like there'd be a new
tweet and they'd be like the other three
tweets and then there'd be a new one and
there was one time we were at a
conference and there was a panel of the
conference talking and Michael are I
continue to sort of this [ __ ] works
on TechCrunch yeah I know but I have no
problem saying that Mike
so he get this thing where he was saying
on Twitter's not me though it's not a
big deal they were fighting dr. wertham
hill and so I started live tweeting
panel and then he brings up the Twitter
homepage and of course the tweeter get
so little traffic at this point my live
tweets giving him [ __ ] about giving the
panel [ __ ] are the only things on so you
know it didn't get a lot of traffic but
the people used it in the first month
the first three months there was only
about 100 users but there were our
friendly thousand messages delivered so
at the time you had to pay to receive
messages so people who used it that
first time is we're paying 3 or $400 a
month to be able to use Twitter in SMS
feeds and that that showed you something
really important which is you really
want something that said like love or
hate relationship like you wanted people
to say what the [ __ ] is this this is
dumb or oh my god I'm gonna pay hundreds
of dollars a month so I can get these
messages and that was exactly sort of
how Twitter grew and so they had these
super fans and people who super hated it
and everyone is really passionate about
it and it started to grow and you know
this is sort of a couple months in what
Twitter look like there's a couple
things you'll notice it has friends and
not followers so the process of making
it sort of blog like took a while to
develop the other thing you notice is
the logo it's twt TR and it was very
mobile and SMS driven so the only way to
sign up for it was sending an SMS to the
thing we used a a little nokia phone and
USB cable and some pirated Windows
software to send and receive the
messages so that you could say they
receive them and that worked for life it
was lonely
you know for a while I was just showing
you 24 hours of tweets and you couldn't
go back in the future beyond that this
was how many texts mr. this person had
received you know 700 text messages we
had lots to complain about that and to
send the tweets you had to leave after
we went from the text the phone to a
service plane to tell you had to prefix
it with things so there were extra codes
and the codes were more complicated than
ended up being so that existed for a
number of months but Twitter didn't take
off it had this small group users who
really loved it and then about this time
which is you know two years in the
company I actually quit I said I'm gonna
go off and work on activism a change the
world again this Twitter thing is you
know but Blaine who was the first to
giving each out kina with me and a bunch
of people stayed and a lady who became
the main programmer on it for a number
of years he didn't have a cell phone cuz
they didn't believe in having cell
phones until he had no way of using and
testing the software he was building and
we had another developer this guy
Florian who lived in Germany and he
couldn't receive the text messages
either and so the two of them without
telling him one hacked up a little
aimbot so that you can chat with Twitter
and just get the messages that way and
so Twitter went from a almost
accidentally a mobile phone driven thing
to something you can get on your desktop
where took a mobile phone but you you
can also handle that stream on the
desktop and then you can start building
on top of it and then because it was
easier to be on Rails an RSS feed was
added so that people be built on top of
it and since removed
and probably the most important thing
for Twitter's growth was the fact that
it all the commands everything you could
do in the web interface you could do by
arrest and there was no authorization
there was no process by which you needed
approval to access the Twitter API in
fact we had no idea who was using the
API it was just you know HTTP off basic
username and password and every command
of the system was available Germany
which means with one page wiki hub this
is how you use the Twitter API hundreds
and applications got created in all
sorts of ways and so that created the
ecosystem it was really vital for its
growth there's you know after a while we
bowels and the applications started
fitting to other display applications
the sort of ambient discussion stopped
started appearing and being possible
about one year after the hackathon
people were still saying that Twitter
was this crazy dumb idea but they were
using it and at the South by Southwest
festival of 2007 he was the first time
you started to see real emergent sort of
blocking and crowd behavior using using
Twitter and it was around finding which
bar at free alcohol it wasn't didn't
have long lines and because of that they
ended up being sort of considered the
darling and after that moment in 2007
after a years were struggling which the
guy and the a mod well as if things got
built then it started to take off after
that Oh Dino got sold off the podcasting
thing in Twitter today is sort of very
similar to that
section several years old but that
that's a sort of a rough history of how
it got created so we we worked on text
from the OTO office on stuff and then
after we gave the keynote of detail on
text mobbin social like social activism
using telephony we spent a week in the
company where every single person signed
up protection of and we made a bunch of
groups and we actually did a usability
and use analysis in the company so
everybody in oh do use text mode for a
week and we also used a couple their
services we used a new POC and a couple
of services and then we had a couple
hour-long whiteboarding session when we
analyzed what didn't didn't work about
text on social problems so that was a
week worth of work of analysis of text
mode that happened a couple weeks before
we built could text mob wasn't the only
thing that went in to Twitter but it was
probably the piece of software in
interaction model we studied most
leading up to the creature
I'm gonna jump in queue here as
moderators privilege and ask you so part
of part of what's interesting about his
talk and the story of that's not been
Twitter is the contrast between a very
complicated story that you're telling
which is that there's a lot of different
things going on there are people coming
there are applications that people are
using as example it's not analyzing and
that's all feeding into the creation
that's cool then there's this there's a
different narrative which is the
corporate origin story in various books
that various founders and journalists
are writing about it which tell the
story of well some really smart Silicon
Valley people were like sitting on a
swing
you know wouldn't have to do the blue
sky and Andy head is the tank going here
the key story here isn't about the
direct influence of a particular
activist technology on what then became
you know this blow up pool that that so
many of us use or is it about the
incredible complexity of the creation of
any new technology or some of those I
think I mean I think I think that you
know it wouldn't have existed without
text mom
it wouldn't have existed if we've been
hadn't built the text book we haven't
used it but the environment in odio was
in some ways similar to what I think the
Media Lab is in some ways we had lots of
people who worked employees who came and
hang out at the office we had lots of
people who had other jobs we had lots of
people who were doing all sorts of
projects you know we weren't very good
at focusing on what we were supposed to
be doing because we did lots of side
projects and played with things you know
there was this guy Duncan whose official
job was to redesign the Apple homepage
and the Apple homepage just doesn't need
redesigning that often and so like
between that and he would spend weeks
just hanging out in her office trying to
build cool stuff and really hacking or
CS
you know we had half the blogger team we
were like I'm taking the bus down to
Google let's just hang out here and then
they would stop doing their day jobs in
like we we built you
and so the reason so there's there's two
reasons why the Twitter story is is is
so narrow one Jack Dorsey who is sort of
most widely known as the creator of
Twitter was an engineer on the project
and the rest of the team thought we were
going to Twitter was gonna be sold
really quickly and the most likely
acquirer was Google and half the team
are like dear God they don't want to go
back to Google and so they picked Jack
as CEO and gave none of the people who
had been at Google any title in the
organization so that the Google people
wouldn't try and convince them to come
back like tied him up with a her never
so that's really how he got named CEO
then they worked on doing it there was a
fight between them and Jack was fired
from the organization this is well known
yeah but he kept his twitter email
address and then he was this that he was
fired so he went on the media when they
asked him and said these guys didn't
create twitter I created Twitter and
everybody has this ability to create
this memory in their own head like the
more you tell a story the more that
story becomes real in your own mind and
so I don't think he was malicious in it
I think he was pissed off at being
pushed out of the organization and so
that story is an easy story to tell it
sounds great the lone genius who has the
idea and so the media has sort of eat it
up but real innovation is real messy so
the reality is that there were 12 people
who participated the hackathons at the
organization to make Twitter and that's
not an easy media story it's not an easy
story to sort of consume and to find who
it is if anybody is the one inventor of
it it's a guy nowa class who came up
with a name
he was the sole founder of OD oh he was
the most passionate person about
whole thing and he was completely
written out again yeah so I'm gonna go
back to the protest because they're
being the most interesting bit of this
was not that innovation is investing
here although innovation it's messy it's
never very simple it was interesting
that to me was how community activism
actually led to concepts watch well you
know text mom couldn't like get off the
ground it's like this thing was used by
millions and millions of people somehow
the combination of transferring concepts
from text mom into this crazy process
that widows and dinner
I wasn't able to reach millions of
people and I'm like I'm gonna I'm going
to mention one thing that you left out
which is you know when we saw the 2011
use of Twitter and Arab Spring I was
like well of course because we had I've
been in the RNC 2004 in his text mom and
it worked pretty well on us the blocking
stuff well you know we had used Twitter
the 2008 hits Republican National
Convention
you know despite various FBI raids and
stuff it has been exceedingly successful
in organizing protesters so I was sort
of like slightly not surprised when this
capacity was picked up by people all
around the world but they didn't seem to
me it seemed like maybe part of the
reason why that happened was off just
hey it's Twitter but also they presented
some of the genetic code from text mob
that was my initial thinking and some
had actually you know because the text
off had been as we've seen clearly use
to organize protests and it was sort of
not surprising everyone to have smart
about it
everyone at Twitter that then the same
dynamics could be used again I mean
there were there were things that were
built into the technology sort of a
philosophy of the open web the
philosophy of anyone connect the
philosophy of you just need a thought
you don't have to text your real
identity the ability for memes and ideas
and links to spread quickly these are
things that you see in activism and
social movements and Twitter dos does
those things well and I think that's
some of the holdover never surprised me
but it wasn't a narrative that Twitter
incorporated wanted like they love being
associated with the protest but they
didn't want anyone to think they were
taking sides so was a narrative that was
downplayed
we can social media social media and the
late 90s early 2000 didn't exist like
the idea that people would cover their
own news and everything else was a
radical concept and now now it sort of
seems on what do you see that session is
around crypto stuff and security and
privacy but uh there there was a problem
with in the media and a bunch of the
activism stuff which was it was much
easier to build software and scale it
within the context of a start-up in the
context of a social movement and so you
saw the core development team of
Craigslist 20 media people the the
architected core development Flickr the
guy who ran and built the way
communities work on YouTube CTO of Etsy
you know a whole slew of these
organizations then even our stuff were
where the activists going into terms so
I think that's a lot of what happened
people attended it whether they're
saying ID
[Music]
that's fascinating so so they're inside
Twitter was tremendous amount of fight
over the direction of the platform at
one point in 2007 or 2008 we have a
bunch of talks on federated social
networks using XMPP and pub sub hubbub
was developed direct accept and so it's
sort of amorphous crew of folks inside
the organization you know the line
between who was Twitter who wasn't in
the early days was very blurry was only
it wasn't like you know I think a lot of
people have rude on all the servers who
weren't employees or had no formal
connection to the organization just
because they wanted to help but uh so it
was actually a point with a service
called jaku that was bought by Google of
worked on Symbian geophones came out of
Finland and at one point the software
was written so that microblogging could
be a medium and there were Federation
between these services so you could
follow someone on another service and
Twitter supported that on a protocol
level and that direction basically that
was abandoned partially because it was
built on XMPP instead of help some above
except you don't simply don't know how
to scale it as well and so when Twitter
lost the person who was most
knowledgeable about how to build and
scale X and PV systems the Federation
was abandoned and then a couple of years
later the Twitter the business people
got afraid that TweetDeck was going to
take over
company then steal their users and so
the ecosystem was abandoned and so there
were all these points in which the
development team said let's make it more
open let's make it a medium like email
and Twitter could be a big fish of a
much larger pond and people said no we
need to control it for ads let's be the
only fish in a very small part and so
the Twitter we see today is the company
that said we don't want the larger
medium we're afraid of it we're gonna do
the thing we control and so that like if
there's anything that I think was a bad
change of direction how do you think
like I think it was a lack of creativity
and a short-sighted decisions because
they could kept the act app ecosystem
and the revenue share with the app
creators so that the app creators then
made money off the ads that were
displayed on people like there's no
reason why they had to walk away from
that
except for sort of rushed decisions made
a few yeah well then turns off
completely but they started shutting
down after that more than a hundred
thousand registered users to Twitter
which exists was because of the API
because they because of so retweets
@replies hashtags those are all created
by use even Twitter search is all
created by third parties and users and
then incorporate it into the platform so
like the lesson of Twitter's innovation
is look at how people use your stuff and
support it and embrace it and that
Twitter stopped its massive growth when
they got afraid and started trying to
control things and stop listening to it
so like the tweet streams is a great
example if you've seen tweet stream is
this app that lets you post alter like
now it's a user innovation of people
using the platform the Twitter as a
corporation as a hip embrace and support
because it's actually used and so the
Twitter used to be as a company
now they've had three generations of
complete turnover in the organization
like no one I you there
know someone whose know you know there
was no other lap tween so when I were
there with someone else you know Isaac
there's so many generations that the
people who work there today don't know
how they got to know they've lost their
own corporate history I'm curious it
sounds like both in your organization
and these other activists you were
talking about with Etsy or went to
YouTube like it seems like kind of a
loss for all these people to go in you
know with these wonderful ideas and then
see it kind of get corrupted through the
process that I'm ordering if you think
you know how do you think these should
be structure to prevent that happening
it sounds like is it bunch of great
people with great intention the
corporate structure just like push
things in a really negative direction
yeah it's tricking out a big believer in
in startups dual licensing or like again
your stuff under an open-source licenses
you know I don't kind of strong opinion
or the MIT first place its person if GPL
but you think an organization like
whispered systems which makes you know
tech secure anything else
whispered systems was an angel back
startup they got funding they got a
quieter by Twitter they could be their
technology there but because they had
dual licensing it was all open-source
licenses after the earn out moxie and
the folks went back and just kept
working on you open mystery scissors so
it let them play in both places and I
think the companies which are trying to
capture users and capture value they
don't actually care that it's dual
license there's open source like like
they care about the the existence of it
there's an alternative path that's an
out they don't care about it so I think
that when people go into these
organizations it's really important then
the core technology get my
licenses so that with the companies make
bad decisions you can keep took one of
Phil's honest office question one of my
hobbies is industrial archaeology
history here of the companies that if
the company doesn't even know its own
history anymore how can anybody else and
how can this how can it be captured in
something other than the self-serving
biographies the founders I mean are you
even thinking about that you talk about
going back to your own email are you I
mean you're thinking of you know finding
a way of keeping the original documents
so this is somewhere somehow there's two
things one being yes a lot of it is just
in my gmail the book having dinner or
hatching twittering or predict building
from the air times which is sort of the
widest read book about created very
focused on the personalities doesn't
really talk about why or where things
came from almost all the original source
material like the direct material is
should I order but the other place you
get this is because we created social
media and all you've got for it was a
short passage about how you were the
anarchist wouldn't stand up and also I
think he used the justification that
there were anarchists involved in the
organization you know to say that's why
Twitter how to disorganize you know was
it was disorganized and had Batman bring
culture you know I mean I could do
things like we were talking about with
the launch and I thought the software
was ready and no one else
I was ready so I just turned the side on
about it too long so me I wasn't saying
that I wasn't a difficult person to
manage in the organization you should
ship software you think it's perfect you
waited too long so the tweets of the
social media the documentation that
exists publicly like that that's like in
some ways we've taken three Twitter
ideas pretty social medias of how you
document your lives and now we
documented online and so now like when I
go back and find like when I go back to
try and remember my own like my own
participation in the old history like
I'm going back and finding okay is there
a recording of the keynote that I gave
talking about you know how we can use
text messages and collecting for
activism the months before the tour
directors created you know that kind of
stuff those sort of like we are creating
a history of it online now part of the
reasoning in this talk is sort of the
same type of thing one of the reasons I
want recorded there's a documentary on
sort of my perspective on the creation
of Twitter and how the role of it coming
out and Al Jazeera English in November
about running the book about talking
about the way in which the interaction
between activism social movements and
technology but it's actually taken me a
while to like say I'm no longer upset
about what is it isn't even history and
trying to figure out what the right way
of not stepping on people's toes and not
take
credit for other people's work but
telling the story as I see it I think
one of the problems is that because no
one at Twitter now knows the history
like the official like some of the
official Twitter accounts saying you
know battle is never there and it's odd
because like I have a Twitter account
that dates from like 10 minutes after
Twitter got started and there's all
these photos of me there and there's
like books like so like the their
Twitter's own PR people they don't know
the history that's actually not uncommon
I mean I visit uh you know the Procter &
Gamble Museum and they did a new museum
director you know who started you know
going through their archives and you
know things like John Wayne air and then
hectic you know trace back the corporate
acquisition history the Gotham John wins
here for the fact that you know
companies don't know where they came
from and even company you know its
biggest Procter & Gamble but you know
we're big enough to have a museum and
the story ends who work for the
what-what was invented here is the
process of self documentation my
question to you is what are you thinking
about in terms of your own archives etc
you know a book sure but beyond that the
original source you know material is
what what's really interesting a lot of
money
let's just take one or two last
questions anyone who hasn't oh yeah so
Olaf was created by Twitter as a way of
attempting to protect users privacy and
it's the way people log into like you
log into Facebook you long you know log
in with there was an years of attempts
to build open ID and identification
systems and login systems they were all
complete failures and bob was an attempt
to standardize the way flickr off works
in a standard open format and so there
were a bunch of open meetings a bunch of
people got the other everybody got
together the Twitter office and said
well we should have a way in which we do
logins we were not sharing these
attachments and so Olaf was created
written into libraries everything else
got adopted a bunch of company the
really ironic thing was a lot was about
redistributing power and protecting
users and Olaf is what made it so the
Twitter could shut down their own app
ecosystem and Olaf has been one of the
most destructive centralizing
controlling technologies that we've
adopted in the web and it was built by a
bunch of anarchists who wanted to
protect users privacy in decentralized
levels so sometimes you can build and
deploy technology that's massively
successful and does politically and
ideologically exactly what you didn't
want Justin to bring this part out for
those who wants but more time with Evan
he'll be around tomorrow at this time
for lunch
with w3c werlla Web Consortium which is
like the web standards body
we're also brainstorming how to fix some
of these
around centralization and a whop
definitely comes up stuff like open
standards for things like Twitter like
streams and Status Messages or something
we're working on
so that's a topless Center on the fifth
floor
yes it's DG 30 that the gates building
on the fifth floors come out you take a
medium right this time tomorrow noon
tomorrow thanks seven nine thanks
everyone
[Applause]